alright and welcome to the video do a 15
minute game again I actually try to the
last couple of days but somehow I waited
so long in those 15 million pool and so
I'm I went 45 minute instead to get
games quicker okay I'm I got a Sicilian
here and try to mix openings here to
play on this line which is um yeah
mostly referred to as the classical line
with Nazi six f6d six you played Bishop
c4 which is mostly called the souls in
attack an old favorite of Bobby Fischer
actually yeah blacks main movie z6 here
um yeah I don't really know the details
here so I need to make up my own theory
here's the game goes on I only know that
white has yeah 22 basic plans to go for
a quick long castle on our short castle
um okay Bishop b3 not quite sure what's
the right to move order here I guess a
6b should be seven and so on should be
fine and I think if white goes for long
castle he usually um keeps the bishop
here for a couple of moves longer so
looks like he's more likely to go for
for short okay
yeah usually if a white goes for long
canceling here he plays Queenie to to
keep the g foursquare covered that they
cannot really play be sure the nitrogen
form and if he wants to Castle short
yeah he would do it now I guess okay
long castling after all but he's got
this Bishop here yeah usually it needs
to move there anyway but I'm not sure if
the Sun is entirely normal
yeah I guess this is the normal position
again not sure if I should castle first
or play something like Knight a5 when b5
a chart Catholic cannot be that bad I
guess you're interesting here is g-form
one point could be a take on d4 let's
say g4 take on d4 Bishop tags and i have
e five the bishop protectant and g for
hanging so maybe you need to recapture
the rook in order to play on e5 Roxy for
which looks somewhat we had but somehow
I think lines of this kind exists but i
also think i'm even look g1 this way let
move here rook hg1 and then g-form white
get them a dangerous attack anyway so
this choice is a bit risky because I
don't really know the deal details if
you play such a sharp line allowed such
a sharp line on you really shouldn't
should know this much better bit riskier
this choice Black has a couple of
earlier alternatives on Bishop c4 these
six is still only only one possible move
okay he plays f3 to prepare g-form this
is not unusual in the English attack or
something but here it is somewhat slow i
think okay should I go from Knight a5
and then be 54 B 5 immediately let's go
on 95
one idea could be b5 and also night of
c4 I don't necessarily want to exchange
the bishop here okay you pre pass 35
what you always need to be well here are
various peace Accra fights on f5 and d5
um but it would be surprising if they
could actually work with them and yeah
maybe it's not not completely ridiculous
maybe there's an idea to move 97 on
before he place for he plays if g5
I'm thinking about maybe play on air on
g 5 maybe play 95f 494 yeah the saw
now 95 95 f 494 what g4i or b-five just
be five what I'd like to do is to to
some pluck something on c4 to to block
this this Bishop here if you place FYI
five this Bishop would get really strong
of course I am I always have the option
to just take it but don't really want to
what I'm asking myself is so b 5 b 5f
for nazi form and then f 50 it looks
really dangerous for black yeah I'm not
used to this none of these some
positions and maybe everything's fine
here but I'm already slightly tariff act
of the deck even if he basically lost
the temple with their three
okay so therefore i play nazi for not
quite sure what i do an f5 of queen bee
one is very slow very slow move ok let's
get in there
I don't really threaten anything yet
well maybe to take only three from a
strategic point of view I don't think he
wants to give up this Bishop but I don't
have any threats yet on on your skin I
don't have anything on the c final yet
ok just this one
I get some tech going I could I could
put this night on b6 and then try to
play B form yeah this is one idea I
could also just take here I could try to
get the rook on the C file to threaten
on be too
I don't know relief I don't like the
position to be honest why it seems to
still have a decent attack here and it's
a well this is so really easy to play it
just needs to put all this stuff forward
this is just just go ahead with the
pawns okay let's say I play be four now
he would go night-night a form doesn't
have any other square
hmm
how to get some counter play here it's
not yet I think threatening g6 I can
just take on g6 and play h6 like you
might be able to sacrifice on h6 this is
dangerous already
okay need to get something going here
the place night a for this would also
distract its pieces some what if i take
Bishop a4 then this is a little bit of
here on a form and i'm not sure if you
get something else some brutal attack g6
or anything similar I don't think so
yeah I needs to play this course on 94 I
could also capture see forward don't
think this should be a huge difference I
could also take here actually okay I'm
already behind on the clock so try to
speed up a bit
okay took on two corner and ce4
yeah maybe try to harass bishop
immediately he goes to be three than a
five-night be five Quincy six and I'm
till it still threatening a form yeah
let's try to play this in a direct
fashion here
a force should be a real threat here
don't think you can ignore it on
something like g6 a form takes f7 I can
capture with the King and protect these
six this way doesn't look too convenient
but I think I need to yeah I have my
reasons why I don't play lines like this
usually I always feel that in this kind
of races um yeah even weaker players
could simply made me just throw
everything towards the king and well if
you do some slight miscalculation you
easily meet a door or run over one thing
actually if you place not be 5a play
Queen c6 if he isn't just retreats to
deform not quite sure if I have anything
else and repeat the position with Queen
c7 looks difficult to um yeah okay I'll
not be five I could play Queen b8 to
play on
hmm maybe this isn't too bad for me
still I am always some fear that there
is some sacrificial breakthrough
even stupid looking stuff let's say just
a fantasy line night f5 I take it and
then he plays g6 and then takes on f7 ok
I've Bishop e6 ok this is just a fan
Jonesy line okay it goes for g6 this is
some of course the really hard hard way
to play yeah a form if it takes on let's
let's try first it takes on h7 then I
just dropped 2h ATM on h6 FG six there
shouldn't be a direct threat damn if it
takes on f7 I recapture with the king
okay could could sacrifice on e6 and
bring my king out 36 which is not ideal
but I could could even then take on b6
play Quincy for trick yeah well I don't
think we're ever choice anyway okay
one line i was considering was takes on
e6 Bishop takes Knight takes King takes
we should be six queen bee six Quincy
for check and then i think i have d 7 as
a as a square k only six is not great
but while a piece is a piece you could
always throw and not be five but i think
i can just retreat to be 80 c6 but then
95 might repeat the position
okay let's check in quincy 6 first okay
then i can actually take and go to c4 on
b6 huh maybe I should try to can i play
Queen c6 first and decide afterwards
what I do it takes on b6 I can also take
on b3 with an intermediate threat on C 2
and a 2 okay let's go here Wow well this
is this is a mouse slip I guess
yeah imma take back quite resign oh no
resigned yeah well I enter take back
take back here actually to a bit spoiled
really spoils the game it was quite
quite interesting Oh shame yeah but
you've resigned immediately i was
offering the take-back not much more
that I can do let's um let's try to UM I
do it quicker analysis here and I'd like
to like to know at least a bit what's
going on with the computer wants to take
any sixth and gives wider winning
advantage if okay oh no no now he
corrects himself interesting prefer
let's check this quickly drop computer
was giving this this line and then this
one yeah but now it says that black is
better not see form cause still very
messy position what else is wrong yeah
this I think 95 from cannot be cannot be
that bad I don't look down somewhat
logical
now it wants to repeat the position but
what is what about about this move isn't
this play will queen bee 7 for instance
or is that some some terrible sacrifice
so not immediately obvious but well
maybe just just scream be five or
something maybe five
here
who looks very dangerous yeah i was i
was in danger here of course but of
course Bishop c5 just just blundered the
game away maybe intended to take on I
guess he intended to take here on b6 but
yeah I played this young ok but I guess
maybe he wanted to he wanted to take
here then I wanted to was my intention
to take here then it should be good for
white elfa black shunted if this Bishop
is gone besides the technical problems
of course yeah it's just winning him
this is this one is just hanging and
yeah black just wins so if you wanted to
take here this is losing anyway yeah I
needs to drop back to d4 here and then
see if I repeat the position or try to
play for wind and maybe he can really
really sacrifice on e6 yeah interesting
game unfortunately spoiled by by this
mall slip I guess ok let's go for
another game